>> Can India become a superpower?
Yes, the answer is definitely yes.
Given the natural resources, the kind of the
domestic settings and what
we have, and the demography and the skills
sets that are available,
definitely India can become a superpower.
But the biggest question there is when?
When is the biggest question.
With the [INAUDIBLE] regulators, definitely
we need a capital markup,
competition to step into the market so that
you pool the domestic
savings.
And I would put that timeframe of ten years,
that is by 2020, we must
see India becoming a superpower given all
the advantages that we have
in terms of manufacturing, in terms of resources,
in terms of skill
sets, and in terms of developments [INAUDIBLE].